thank you for joining my name is Mark uh
I'm gonna start with
um a story
so I used to work at Lyft
and at left I was in the data team
during this time
uh lift
was growing really quickly and I
remember talking to a data scientist who
worked in the ETA team
ETA is the time a driver takes to pick
you up
and this person had built a new model
for ETS and ETA and pricing are the two
biggest factors that helped Lyft make
money
and this person had built this new model
and I was chatting with them like how's
it going and this person says oh well
the model is ready but I can't deploy it
I'm like why can't you deploy it because
I don't know what to compare it against
in my data warehouse
and I was like why is that and he made
me pull up my apples living in the San
Francisco Bay area at that time he's
like
you open the app it says your driver's
two minutes away you put in your
destination like Fremont California
which is by the way like kind of like
Cedar Park in Texas no one goes there
and then the ETA becomes like seven
minutes then you say I'm gonna take a
line ride and the ETA is 10 minutes and
the driver actually shows up 12 minutes
later right so even in that session I
measured ETA four times we've had
previous models of etas that are all
logging data to the warehouse and there
were 20 models in the past 20 times
fours that's 80 columns right there this
dude had joined the company three months
ago so of course in just the ETA of real
data that's being logged in the
warehouse there were 80 options and of
course they had no idea what was the
source of truth right
and so that pushed me to create a
product that left called the data
catalog the name of that product was
amundsen that was super successful we're
going to talk a little bit about that
product today
um
but that product used proxy of
popularity to kind of tell you what's
trustworthy based on what other people
are using
however that was 2018 and the more time
I've spent on this problem The more I've
realized that the problem of solving
that problem at the back end which is
using the popularity to drive trust is
actually thinking about it all wrong and
what we need to do is instead of dealing
with this issue later on with all the
data we have we need to go further
upstream and try to reduce
um the hey in our Haystack or drain the
swamp so there's easier for the
alligators to muddle through so that is
the The Talk today I'll start with a
little bit of my background I started my
data Journey working as a engineer on
spark at Cloudera from there I went to
Lyft there's going to be a little more
conversation about Lyft that's where I
created that project that no one can
stay or remember how to spell
um that project was pretty successful at
Lyft used uh by 750 users every week
and uh called the Munson it was then
used by instacart doordash brex workday
ing Square many others in the open
source from there I left to start the
next generation of that product
company called stema product called
stemma and today we are a data catalog
used by companies like Sofi iRobot
Convoy grafana so on and so forth
cool so this problem of data Discovery
this idea of the data scientist working
on the ETA team uh there's a lot of
wasted time and this was a analysis that
I did during that time where the first
part of the Journey of an analytics
workflow is discovery which is like okay
I'm gonna look at like what were my
orders last week and I'm gonna find that
uh I need to know where the source of
truth of this information is what do I
need to join with what in order to get
that information then I do some
exploration maybe I do some data quality
like make sure it's like it's in the
ballpark of what I'm looking at then I
go actually write a dashboarding or an
analytical model and then I communicate
that model right and the thing was that
the first
two pillars there 35 percent of the time
was being spent in that like what do I
need to use do I have it can I trust it
and a third of analytics time being
spent on that felt like it was a huge
opportunity to reduce right and so that
pushed me to create this product
amundsen uh this is a little bit of a
graph of that and how much love it got I
left so you know there are holidays when
you see dips but overall up into the
right in terms of usage patterns
analysts love it there was a slack
Channel where there was an on-call
person every week people would just come
ask this person questions you have this
this channel in your in your company
where like people just come and ask data
questions yeah and then this channel
person there was one data scientist a
week that was answering these questions
and that person said like hey I felt
like in the first week I could answer 50
of the questions just by saying like let
me almonds in that for you
anyway this is a little more about the
community so uh a bunch of these
companies I already mentioned
and I thought like solving this problem
with amundsen was solving all the
problems right uh and I was wrong and
the reason is that Amazon used
popularity which is how many queries are
happening on our table to uh use
uh to power ranking so if all the other
data scientists in the company are using
this particular column joining this
table with that table querying this
particular table in this way then maybe
you should too that was the core thesis
of the product but
what I found was that more and more data
was being generated and it felt more
that
um the problem uh if we had to solve it
in a sustainable long-term way that we
needed to control how data was being
generated and that pushed me to notice
that in software engineering we make
changes to our software very often right
you've got some function you delete that
there's a compiler that compiles it
there's dependency managers who make
sure nothing is broken and then we every
week if not more often will delete code
but deleting data is something we don't
do right and there's a reason behind
that so we did some research and I'll go
into that moment but
the process of deleting data is uh very
Voodoo right now and because of that if
you delete data there's a high chance
that there's some stakeholder somewhere
who's going to get surprised by it and
come and bite you later right and that
is the real uh reason I think we are not
making changes to data
so there are two perspective to making
changes to data I'll start with one
story just last week I live in a very
crappy apartment building in Redmond
Washington I was uh taking a shower I
still take showers even though I work
from home and I was taking a shower and
I've got my soap lathered on me and I'm
washing my face and the water goes out
and I'm like my eyes are itching I'm
like not having a good time and then uh
I yell at my wife as to what's going on
and she doesn't know either and later
thankfully I've managed to somehow wipe
my face and figure it out by reaching
out to the apartment building that there
was a scheduled maintenance of this
water being turned off from my building
and I didn't know anything about that
right the reason the story is relevant
is because when we data engineers make
changes to data this is how data
analysts feel right this is like oh
I had this model I was gonna go into an
exec meeting I have the dashboard pulled
up but
the data is not there
and the other side is the poor data
Engineers right the data Engineers
they'll go to the slack Channel where
all the analysts are hanging out and
they're like hey by the way next Monday
they're my apartment building right next
Monday from 9 A.M to 5 p.m you're we're
doing some schedule maintenance or by
the way more likely the scenario is
starting Monday this qualum is no longer
the source of truth because we changed
our CRM from this thing to that thing
and you need to start using this other
thing right and not just that the data
engineer told them once on Monday a week
before they told them once on Wednesday
and they told them once on Friday with
big flashy slap slack emojis right but
the analysts didn't they didn't pay
attention so like obviously on Monday
their dashboard is not working right so
we have a pretty terrible situation
right an analyst feeling like you are
pulling the wrong from underneath my
feet and then a data engineer feeling
like oh I try to feed you right but you
were an alligator who comes after me
because I told you three times I'm gonna
make this change and you still didn't
listen right so I want to give you two
real examples obviously I won't name
these companies but these are companies
we've talked to work with where this
situation materialized so company number
one
what they're trying to do like a bunch
of companies in this economic condition
is trying to reduce the amount of spend
that they have within their data right
by the way the amount of spend there's a
few different sources
ETL and computer two major ones turns
out ETL is almost always the largest one
uh and so like most companies are
looking at their ETL spent they had this
table that was costing them a ton of
money in ETL the analytics team
rigorously vetted out to make sure no
one was using this table they deleted
that table right what they didn't
realize was that this table was being
used by a service account which was not
going to show up in your DBT repo it
wasn't going to show up in your lineage
graph anywhere right that was a high
touch account that was taking that data
putting that into their marketing system
which was then sending emails to people
right all this got screwed up because
they deleted that table and in this case
they did all their diligence right let's
talk about example number two this is
this company
had a Sandbox schema right so we try to
do self-serve and what you do is you end
up creating a Sandbox for some analyst
to go build a table for themselves they
build a table and they always say like
hey I'm gonna only use it for this one
use case trust me it's only going to be
for this one use case right what happens
is that use case happens another analyst
finds that particular table and they're
like oh this is almost what I want so
I'm gonna just extend it a little bit
and I'm gonna use it for my use case the
the the sad part of the story is data
team doesn't know about this the analyst
who may have created this doesn't know
about it just gets reused right and so
what happened in this particular case is
that this this particular table was
created by one analyst started being uh
bastardized for use and another uh a use
case and then off comes a meeting in
which
one analyst the second analyst who who
opened this up and another person
brought two numbers to the meeting and
the numbers were wrong right so uh I'm
sure we've never heard that before and
data teams started getting blamed for
providing untrustworthy data when all
they wanted to do was enable the first
analyst for an ad hoc self-service use
case right
and so what we did was like okay there's
a lot of pain around this changing of
data problem so what exactly is going on
and we ask people questions in three
categories first one was how often are
you making changes to data the second
one is uh what tools and process do you
use in order to make these changes to
data and the third one is what is your
sentiment around making these changes to
data which parts do you love which parts
do you hate so on and so forth here's
what we found
we found that data engineers
loved spending time on data modeling
solving bugs scoping out long-term
projects and this is no surprise to
anybody what if they hate they hated
ruling back changes right I just made
this change you have to use this table
and then someone says like oh how come
you used how come you made this change
we need to align and talk in their
meetings and actually you end up rolling
this change back and the difficulty of
making data changes was three out of
five higher the worst but the difficulty
of migrating users was foreign that
means that I can do my work off like
whatever new ETL job I need to create
maybe I pause an existing ETL job but
all you people who are built on top of
my table that have like ETL running
dashboards running ad hoc queries
running reverse ETL jobs running I got
no way uh to coordinate that so what
ends up happening is just a bunch of
slack messages that get blasted on on
slack right 20 of them had done no form
of impact analysis of who's going to be
impacted and it's kind of like spray and
pray right and then
um
this the status not here but 70 of them
just hated the process absolutely
and so this is what happens
60 of them did blast and so here's an
example of what happens Rob our data
Engineers like Hey we're migrating for
orders to core orders new this will
affect all exec dashboards watch out big
yelling letters and then a few days
later Michael's like oh I'm noticing my
exact dashboard is not working what is
going on and then there's an eight
message long thread tell Rob telling
Michael be like hey dude told you and
Michael's like oh I was on vacation I
missed it right
this is the current process
and parts of what works and what doesn't
so the first part is a data engineer
Scopes out the change uh the next step
is usually investigating usage this part
almost always gets skipped right there
are no tools to good tools for most
organizations to investigate who's
really using my data then comes a blast
to users
this is a slack message we saw and then
in theory the next step is checking
table usage this also doesn't happen
ideally what you want to do is you want
to send out a message and you want to
see the usage go down and then if it's
not going down you send out another
targeted message and that doesn't happen
so ideally you want to see check table
usage this is not happening if the usage
is not decreasing you are caught in the
loop you can't make that change until
people have reduced their usage and a
lot get caught in this Loop today okay
so say hope the usage is changing maybe
it's all go down to zero you execute the
change and lo behold you fear that no
Angry user shows up on the day you made
that change and if no one shows up your
change is complete and if someone shows
up you go back to square two uh of doing
this change again and this was uh very
common
so the reality is I've talked a lot
about this problem right but this
problem is solvable and the key to
solving this problem is understanding
where usage comes from so there are
three kinds of usage uh that comes the
first one is ETL usage so this is like
your elt or ETL queries that are
generating data second one is analytics
usage so it's ad hoc queries being run
on your data through data grip to
snowflake UI to so on so forth and the
third one is machine usage so this can
be uh usage from ml models reverse ETL
uh things of that sort
and so what I wanted to do was I wanted
you to walk away with some tactical
things you could do to better understand
how data is getting used so this is a
query and there's a blog post at the end
that I'll share which has all these
queries as well but snowflake now
exposes
query exhaust to you which means that
you can run a query like this which will
tell you the LA in the last seven days
how many people have queried a given
table by the way we recommend that you
query it for 90 days why because
sometimes the analysis that's done is
quarterly and if you just queried it for
seven days you would be able to you will
miss out on the quarterly analysis
the second thing is that this only works
for warehouses that support the sort of
pre-processed output out of their query
logs and there are two warehouses that
do that today Snowflake and bigquery so
if you're on that
um you're good and if you're not on
those this option is not available to
you another gotcha to keep in mind is
that snowflake quarries have a lot of
um idiosyncrasies for example the data
in this Norfolk query logs is only
available I believe for 14 days by
default which means if you have to go 90
days you have to accumulate an ETL these
query logs into a table of your own and
manage that ETL process to have a 90-day
enough buffer in order to do that cool
so that's one query ad hoc query usage
on snowflake the second thing is if
you're using DBT DBT allows you to
generate docs these docs actually have
this lineage graph which shows you table
level lineage and you can simply do DBT
docs generate and DBT docs serve in
order to understand your ETL usage from
those
uh the tricky part about this is DBT
docs is uh sucks in performance and it
sucks in user experience and so it's not
something that you would feel proud like
looking passing it on to someone else
and uh it also is only at table level so
you can't get any information about
column lineage
um that the pro tip here is that you
want to delegate ownership
responsibility right so if you find that
I am the owner of this particular thing
that I am deprecating and there's a
downstream owner you want to pass on the
responsibility and trickle it to that
person so they can manage uh their users
off the table using some of the same
tools that you're using lastly you have
to get usage from the bi tools now this
is also not consistent but a product
like Tableau offers you an API so in
this case I'm looking at an API which
gives you the list of Upstream tables
given a tableau dashboard can you tell
me what are the Upstream tables that
this one comes from and the reverse of
this API this output is what tells you
what dashboards are built on top of this
uh this table so all I'm trying to say
is that if you're using a data warehouse
that supports pre-processed query logs
if you're using a bi tool that has an
API that allows you to read uh in
pre-pass lineage parsing for their
dashboards if you use DBT you can stitch
together usage information that's very
helpful for you as a data engineer to
understand the usage
Tableau API in particular is very
cumbersome to use most products will not
give you the list of pre-parsed tables
so they will only give you queries that
are being run by the bi tool and you
would have to do query parsing in order
to generate the list of tables
so process in an Ideal World if you had
all this information is you would use
the exact tables that are impacted by a
change you would make Downstream changes
that you can make yourself in the DBT
repo and then you will submit them to
review by those owners right so I am
modifying the downstream ETL jobs and
creating PRS for my peers who are data
engineers and I'm also making
changes to Tableau dashboards which are
essentially copies because Tableau
dashboards are not versioned and sharing
them with the downstream users and you
can automate a lot of this because of
the apis that are provided and make
those changes a lot more often a lot
more quicker
and the ecos system is evolving too so
what you will find is that this whole
process making changes relies on a lot
on you in order to do query parsing look
at Tableau lineage but catalogs like
stema the company I founded actually
track this usage across a variety of
different tools and I'll show you uh
exactly in a moment how and then we also
allow you to make changes and
communicate these changes to the
downstream owners so instead of sending
slack blasts you're actually sending
very targeted messages to people who own
those tables
the second thing that's happening is
that their bi tools are going in two
categories there's a category of tools
that make
um reviewing a part of the product
itself so an example here is hex which
allows you to do a PR style proposal to
an existing notebook and the second
category is where products have apis to
modify dashboards but there's no
construct to do review which means that
you can create a new dashboard that's a
new version of an existing dashboard and
ask the owner to compare and contrast
ultimately the more comfortable you can
get with making changes to data reduces
the amount of clutter and lack of
control you have in your warehouse and
makes the problems around data Discovery
data management data governance data
quality pii a lot more manageable
because you can very comfortably make
changes to data just the way you would
make it to source code so I want to show
you
um
some screenshots of stamma which provide
you an insight into what that could look
like in a pro what looks like in a
product these screenshots have been
plastered in three in one slide uh and
if you if you want a deeper demo it's on
stema.ai but the leftmost screenshot
actually shows you lineage so this is
what Tableau dashboards and what tables
have already been built on top of this
data here you're looking at a table you
see Upstream but an impact analysis most
important to you is Downstream so here
you're looking at this column called
user ID which is the filtered by column
and that allows you to see that there's
one table that's Downstream and you can
see the distance which is one level
Downstream how popular it is which tells
you the number of queries that that
dashboard has gotten and from how many
users and that's a lot of information
for you to be armed with knowing whether
that's a highly used Downstream table or
not so highly used Downstream table and
that's the first chart on the top left
on the top right what you see is
frequent users now these are your ad hoc
users that are querying the table this
goes as far back as 90 days 90 days like
I said before and so you can see any
user who squared my table in the last 90
days who that person is how many queries
have they run what source did they run
the queries from whether those mode
looker Tableau hex something else and
when was it that you saw the query from
them last and that shows up in the
frequent users category and lastly you
can visualize all that in a lineage
graph most lineage graph and
organizations are complex so they look
great in demos but in practice they
don't work and
um
I have a biased opinion that we have
spent a ton of time with customers with
complicated lineage graphs and making
that work but in general what you want
to do is you want to be able to filter
out a graph very quickly and be able to
use it in a very managed way and uh
filtering out May mean like oh I only
want to filter at this particular column
that shows me all the downstream
dependencies for that and that's an
example we're showing in that screenshot
there's more about this on the website
you can reach out to me at Mark stema.ai
I'll leave you with this one thought if
we could make changes to data with
asthma's confidence as we make changes
to software the problems that are
Downstream around data quality
governance data management become a lot
simpler so if there's one thing you want
to take away from this that's all thank
you
[Music]